says they're gonna live are we actually
live we get that we're life
alright awesome alright hello everyone
and welcome to round table with the
stream team and this is where we sit and
talk to content creators about their
journeys and what they've done to become
what they are today and how you know
everything is evolved and everything is
working well today we have Delilah HD
with us how are you doing I'm doing
great thanks for inviting me and uh
looking forward to the discussion sounds
great I'm happy that you were able to
join us on you know such a last-minute I
apologize for us kind of organizing a
little late it's definitely definitely
my bad because my my weeks have been a
little a little crazy but yes so we have
the other members today for the panel we
have MJ is a Bossier what is going on
dude so oh you know what's going what's
going on I'm gonna I'm gonna nag you to
use that line every single time but pop
yes exactly
I'm getting the email man you're gonna
have the emote made I go talk to the
higher-ups to see if we can add that in
so you guys have a fun little what's
poppin anymore for that and then we have
also our good friend l-boogie here hey
what's up guys how are you pretty good
it's an extra day of the weekend so I'm
happy
isn't it nice isn't it nice to just you
know get up and you're just like I don't
have to write I can just sit here I can
just you know I watch TV play apex
legends all day pretty much just you
know ponens some noobs yeah wish though
it's like awesome always be closing
well the ring just continuously closes
from the start of the game oh yes it's
awesome like it's really cool
does it force engagements more often
yeah oh that's nice or you know till I
can go out and then you're constantly
running in
yeah I don't think something a faster
game like is it you know I don't think
we're live YouTube still hasn't clicked
over yeah kinda I know for us we had
issues to worry this dream key changed
on us and got to I got some notification
on my phone but all my computer won't
load that's a waiting yeah I got the
notification tuned on my phone but it
just says like waiting what are you
doing some YouTube yeah I don't know
they've been having issues oh let me
kill it and start again